joins us live from outside the rubble of
the al jazeera offices
in gaza safwa we were talking to you in
the last hour
and i'm going to say this i'm going to
make it kind of personal
i was very impressed the way that the
operation
the al jazeera operation in gaza was
understandably
shut down for minutes and then you and
your team
relocated you plugged in the satellite
and you carry on doing the job
of a journalist so this unsubtle
horrible attempt at trying to silence
the voice of journalism
is clearly not working because you and i
are having this conversation on this
channel
yes and we will continue having this
conversation
for until the end of the escalation we
will keep reporting
we will have we will use more other
plans
to keep to continue our reporting yes
here in the background you could see
my colleagues uh they were back to uh
to the rubble of the destroy building
they uh they tried to find uh or to pick
up some of the usable
uh equipments hopefully that some of
these equipments are
are usable also our colleagues and al
jazeera arab
they have they started reporting
immediately
using plan b also we could see
people returning back
to their destroyed apartments
looking for precious and important
things
could be documents could be a jewelry
could be
like one of the the neighbors who said
uh that he came back to look for some
paints that his daughter have been doing
and painting
uh because these paints and other things
carry
lots of memories for each family
uh we uh we had to leave everything
behind us including our memories
including our uh years of work including
the archive that
has uh that carries lots of
experience a lot of important material
that we can
we can use let's let's keep
continue uh let's say reporting
on the other side of the gaza strip we
just learned
that the israelis have bombarded another
high building
which is 13th floor building in near the
coastal line of gaza city
there used to be in this building called
some media outlets we
we couldn't confirm it yet if the if
they have been
staying in this building or not but also
we
we we could realize and we could see
that
the the israelis are escalating
and promoting their level of escalation
so they are moving from a stage to
another
so they started with low scale
bombardments
low scale targets and now they they they
start hitting
high buildings that include media
outlets with something
a new in the latest in the latest
escalation
on the other hand also the palestinian
fighting groups
they never stop responding as they say
responding or retaliating for the
israeli attacks
and they also the palestinian fighting
groups they consider
that hitting or bombarding these
residential
buildings as one of the red lines
that the israelis have crossed they uh
the spokesperson of
uh the military wing of hamas well known
as abu ubaidah
he said that they will keep hitting tel
aviv
and the longer range uh rockets towards
tel aviv uh beersheva and and other
cities
the thing that they have already started
in the early afternoon
today the hospitals in gaza they say
that they have
they have been receiving more bodies and
more injured people as you said that
still the number
uh the number of of people who who died
so far are
140 people including about
40 uh children and more than 20 women
killed
and more than a thousand of palestinians
that
have been injured in the la in the uh in
the latest or the last
six days of escalation egypt opened its
borders exceptionally today
to receive and treat this these waves of
injured people that the minister of
health
are not able to deal or treat because of
the difficulties that the health system
is facing
uh uh going back to the borders also in
the north of gaza strip
still it is a flaming area we could hear
the alter
israeli artillery uh bombarding along
the
borderline east of gaza city and
also in the north of gaza which forced
hundreds of families to leave their
homes
and take from you and run schools as
shelter
southward for the moment please stay
with us because i just want to uh
go to another shot that we've got coming
into us because there is
in that densely populated downtown area
of gaza there is another residential
town
in that area where the israeli army has
warned people
to evacuate so what you're looking at
right now is very quiet area because
people have been told
to leave the area it's located adjacent
to the gazan finance ministry
what's going to happen there soon
soon-ish
impossible to know impossible to predict
impossible to speculate
so we won't do that
but as i say people there have been told
to leave the area let's go back to my
colleague uh
safwat uh who was reporting live from
the rubble that's been left behind after
that media building was taken down
so southwark we've had an official
reaction from the associated press we've
had an official reaction
from the al jazeera media network
any reaction from either the gazan
authorities or indeed perhaps even
hamas
well the the only reaction we got uh
so far is from uh the the palestinian
journal it's in decade
they believe that according to what they
said this is
israeli attempt to shut our mouths in
gaza
and to ban the media from telling the
truth
so far this is uh and of course lots of
other
independent association related
association
including also the governmental press
office they condemned
this uh the attack on al jazeera office
or on this in
our building and other immediate outlets
as well
because also we three days ago
they hit another building which was uh
right behind our
uh our office which is where uh
there were more other international and
local media offices as well
so there is uh we have received lots of
sympathy also
from other palestinian journalists and
other
palestinian media groups they all even
they
we receive phone calls from many of them
even offering their help to keep us
on air to keep us reporting yes there is
a big sympathy here in gaza
uh they all condemned the uh such
israeli action
and we haven't from hamas and other
fighting groups
or under political groups still we have
not received
any any related statement or reaction as
we are having our conversation
southward i'm aware that the israeli
military is repeating
again its justification for taking down
the building
that al jazeera used to be based in
alongside the associated press they're
saying
they had evidence i guess would be the
word they would use that there were
hamas paramilitary and military assets
in that building were you ever
aware of anything that could have been
labeled or misconstrued or identified as
being
one assumes hamas military assets
in that tower block
i have been working in this uh office
for more than 10 years
and i have never seen myself and and
even i asked my colleagues if guys you
have seen anything suspicious
they all confirmed to me that they have
never seen
any uh of uh related or
military actions or military aspects or
any of the the
the the fighters even uh
coming in and out in our building we
have
uh lots of families that we
know for more than now ten years uh
living together
uh me almost we meet each other every
day
in our way in and out to the office
on the other hand okay the israelis say
that
they have concrete evidence of
of military activity inside the building
this is 11 floor building and they have
one of the most advanced technology
for military technology so if they know
if they have this concrete evidence i'm
not are
telling them to to bombard it or to fire
it but
why didn't they just hit this apartment
or this facility that they claim some
militants are using it
why they had to destroy 11th floor
building
and uh keep lit hundreds
actually tens of families uh without
shelters
in the streets so they could simply from
the
military or from the logic point of view
they could simply hit these uh
facilities or these offices
or these apartments that they claim they
were used by
fighting groups or by for military
purposes
staff what uh thanks very much we'll
come back to you i'm sure
in the coming hours i'll call you
they're reporting live
from gaza